all right so we got one more story for
you lad when I talk to the table we're
talking about actor writer and singer
Anthony Rapp he's perhaps most
recognized for his role in the Smash Hit
Broadway musical Rent but you may also
know him for other roles like Star Trek
Discovery where rap plays half of the
Star fleet's first openly gay couple now
he's about to open a one-man show here
in New York Vlad caught up with rap
during rehearsals and learned about the
show's intimate look back at his life
and work
Elizabeth I'm hearing a lot of room
suddenly too life has come full circle
for Anthony Rapp in that case maybe you
can back down on the DI just a little
bit as he works out the Kinks in his
one-man show before opening night
without you
[Music]
[Applause]
the days of inspiration
it's his most personal work looking back
on the loss of both his mother and
friend Jonathan Larson The Man Behind
the musical Rent
this theater is incredibly intimate but
you like that I like that a lot yeah I'm
telling the story to people so it's nice
for me to be able to feel their presence
what am I supposed to say here I don't
know rap's career is like a buffet
something for everyone that's a
completely unreasonable expectation to
Bear if you're a Trekkie I'm such a nerd
and fan that I've never pictured myself
in it you guys are actually signing this
craft or if you like classic films Daisy
views was my favorite film I've ever
done really totally
our musical's your thing and if you had
said beforehand oh yeah rock opera about
a group of friends in this village with
a drag queen and interracial gay
relationships and you know that's going
to be a huge success
no one was you would have been laughing
yeah he says all these projects have
something in common daising confused
tells the truth Star Trek being in the
future in space tells the truth rent
tells the truth truth it's what led him
to come out as gay as a young man even
if that meant some difficult moments
would you describe your relationship
with your mom as close yes as a child
very close as a young adult who had a
little bit of
distance around when I came out like it
wasn't bad but it wasn't like sewn up in
a bow as your career started to take off
what did she think of what you were
doing well I mean she was really proud
and excited and then there were moments
he was like because I would start to do
some really dark and interesting and
weird things and she's like why can't
you just play someone normal
when rap landed the role of Mark Cohen
in the musical Rent First on stage and
later in the movie his career hit a high
note the smash show was considered
groundbreaking
there had been a vacuum for this kind of
Storytelling
there had been a vacuum in theater for
something that felt this visceral and
raw and real and real yeah playwright
Jonathan Larson and rap grew close as
the show ran through workshops and
rehearsals
tragically Larson died the day before
rent made its debut Off-Broadway
the fact that he wasn't there just
tilted everything in this really strange
way but it also made us
collectively that much more committed to
it from January 24th which was the dress
rehearsal until July no one missed a
performance
that never happens on any show let alone
a show as demanding as read right around
the time that rent moved to Broadway
rap's mom had begun her losing battle
with cancer it was likely to be the last
thing she'd ever see me do when she was
able to see which was Broadway opening
night she was sat in the front row of
the mezzanine and I could look at her
the whole show and that visual
sensory memory is with me right here
forever
[Music]
there is
time and rent was momentous rap's recent
pass has been two in 2017 rap accused
fellow actor Kevin Spacey of sexually
molesting him at a New York party when
rap was only 14. this past October a
jury in a Civil Trial found Spacey not
liable do you take heart in knowing that
even if the outcome wasn't just in your
mind that there will be other people who
will be inspired by what you did 100 it
is not easy to sit in that courtroom a
courtroom is not a friendly place for
complicated traumatic dark experiences
and on a happier note as his life moves
forward rap and his Husband Ken recently
welcomed a baby boy
[Music]
us I was weirded out and freaked about
the idea about like a newborn I've not
been around that many newborns I've been
around some babies when I first held him
this tiny seven pound four ounce body
was like I'm here
so I'm like okay chills I can do this
with all the developments in his life
now seems like the right time for his
one-man show an opportunity to look back
and remember when you think about your
life and your career are you satisfied I
mean I knew years ago when I first did
rent if this was the best it was ever
going to be that would be enough and now
to get to do this full circle
honoring of all that this is all yes
this feels like bonus
[Music]
Without You opens on Wednesday at the
new world stages in New York City and
runs through the end of April and season
five of Star Trek Discovery has just
finished shooting and will be coming to
Paramount plus Anthony Rapp is one of my
heroes that's why I wanted to do this
story as soon as I knew that he was
doing this one-man show I reached out to
Shawna and to Christopher and said we
have to talk to Anthony because
everything that he's done has been a
cultural Touchstone in my life from
Dazed and Confused to Star Trek and to
rent which it all has in common right
truth truth truth yeah he's a
fascinating character
and let us all get to a point in our
work where it just feels like bonus yeah
right yes for sure he's living his best
life